in a last-minute special session
colombia's conservative majority
congress passed a new controversial
security law that the opposition says
violates human rights
the bill is the government response to a
wave of crime that followed the pandemic
lockdowns but critics believe that while
it claims to guarantee citizen security
with tougher penalties it also violates
the constitution dangerously expanding
self-defense laws among other provisions
this bill allows private citizens to use
a weapon on their property
let's say if peasant farmers invade the
land of a big landowner it can shoot and
kill them and take justice in their own
hands it will bring new violations of
human rights in a country that already
has a terrible record in that regard
the law also increases penalties for
damaging public infrastructure or when
protesters wear a mask and it comes as
the government is under pressure for the
police response to the economic and
social protests that rocked the country
in 2019 and again this year a recent u.n
report documents various instances of
unnecessary and disproportionate use of
force by police officers that left two
dozens dead and criticized armed
civilians shooting at demonstrators
but the country's defense minister who
controls the police said the law does
not legalize these actions
this law does not violate peaceful
protests in any way but when crimes are
committed it assures the police and the
justice system that they can bring those
responsible to justice this law responds
to people's needs for security and
protection
while some mayors applaud elements of
the bills especially the tougher
penalties critics say they will
challenge the law in the country's
constitutional court and will denounce
it internationally
security expert jairo librero says the
court will likely reject the most
liberal articles of the bill
it's a typical example of punitive
populism people want to see those who
commit a crime rot in jail and you can
understand that from a victim's
perspective but the rule of law
regulates things in a different way we
can't forego people's constitutional
rights
colombians have been hoping for an
improvement in security and at the same
time a more humane police for a long
time the government says this new law
will do that reducing crime across the
board but many are asking if it indeed
will and at what cost alessandra
al jazeera